und die SPD hat ein Entwurf schon
Formular und vorgelegt zur
Staatsbürgerschaft die soll jetzt
reformiert werden und seitdem gibt es
Streit eigentlich sollte es schon längst
verabschiedet werden wenn es nach SPD
und Grüne gibt aber die Liberalen machen
dann nicht mit wieso sie sind nicht die
bösen wie es immer dargestellt wird von
anderen Medien nein die Liberalen sagen
wir brauchen klares Bekenntnis zum zu
unserem Grundgesetz zu unserer
demokratisch
Ordnung die wir haben in dem Land und
vor allem Antisemitismus die historische
Verantwortung was ist damit wie testen
wir überhaupt dass Millionen Menschen
und das und die sind davon profitieren
tatsächlich mit unserem Grundwerten
übereinstimmen und das fehlt gerade in
diesen entwurften ich halte diesen
Entwurf so wie er jetzt ist ehrlich
gesagt von Demokratie Risiko denn schon
denn statt acht Jahre soll es jetzt
plötzlich generell fünf Jahre sein dass
man in Deutschland eingebürgert werden
kann bei besonderer Integrationsleistung
sind es nur drei statt sechs das viel zu
schnell und ich finde die
Staatsbürgerschaft wird da mit zu einem
turbopass und sie wird verschenkt Herr
steiniger sind die Worte Turbo passt und
verschenkt zu viel oder genau richtig
also ich tu mir mit den Begriffen schwer
aber jetzt kommen wir zur Sache ich
finde den Vorschlag nicht gut ich finde
das so wie es der Fall ist dass man nach
acht Jahren sich entscheiden kann möchte
ich Teil dieses Landes werden sage ich
Ja zu Deutschland finde ich absolut
ausreichend weil man muss sich ja
erstmal auch integrieren und da finde
ich acht Jahre so wie es der derzeitige
Rechtszustand ist finde ich finde ich
eigentlich gut es wird immer
argumentiert wir brauchen Fachkräfte aus
dem Ausland und ähm damit ich Fachkräfte
nach Deutschland bringen kann müssen wir
denen die Staatsbürgerschaft geben
welche top ausgebildete in der
beispielsweise kommt denn nach
Deutschland weil er vielleicht schneller
deutscher werden kann ja der will
vielleicht auch gar nicht deutscher
Staatsbürger werden der hat eher das
Problem dass ihm hier viel zu viel von
seinen von seinem Gehalt abgezogen wird
dass er zu viel Beiträge gezahlt das ist
das was Deutschland sozusagen
unattraktiv macht für Fachkräfte aber
doch nicht die Frage ob jetzt jemand
nach acht fünf oder drei Jahren
deutscher Staatsbürger werden will und
ich habe gesagt anderer Stelle mal
gesagt eine Staatsbürgerschaft ist jetzt
nicht sowas wie die
Vereinsmitgliedschaft von Hertha BSC
oder FC Bayern wo man auch mal sagt okay
das wechselt man einfach so sondern man
muss schon auch klar Ja sagen zu einem
Land und da finde ich diese Änderung
einfach falsch ich habe da nämlich mal
eine andere Theorie oder so ein Gedanke
wenn die Politik die jetzt seine Macht
ist natürlich ihr politisches Überleben
sichern möchte braucht sie mehr Wähler
ihre Leistungen sind nicht dazu
ausgelegt aber wenn ich natürlich
richtig erinnert hat Frau Bär Bock jetzt
gesagt möchte dann noch mal 10 Millionen
holen dann sind doch 10 Millionen wenn
sie eingebürger sind billige Fehler und
wir sehen ihn dann vielleicht doch ihre
Dankbarkeit heraus aber wir sollten
nicht ver
wir sollten sich verschenken ich kann
dich auch nicht einfach nach Amerika
gehen und bekommen dann einfach alles
wir verschenken hier was und das ist
darauf aufgebaut dass unser Grundgesetz
eingehalten wird dass die Würde des
Menschen eingehalten wird und wer sich
daran hält ist auch gern gesehen und
darf auch unseren Pass haben aber wenn
wir es verschenken machen wir es hier
zum Basar was ist denn das jetzt hier
für eine Mentalität geworden das ist
schon lange nicht mehr irgendwie geplant
indem ich mal groß geworden wenn du mehr
Werte vorgelebt hat wo sind diese Werte
für die wir stehen ich muss dazu
alles machen können weil ich gerade auch
so emotional berührt bin aber jetzt
gerade wieder und zwar ist halt ganz
wichtig wir hatten gerade
silvesterantale Wo ist wochenlang in den
Medien diskutiert wurde auch bezüglich
wieder der Gewalt mit Menschen
Migrationshintergrund und besonders ihre
Partei hat vor Aufsehen gesorgt mit der
Debatte und die Namen was ich auch nicht
gut fand aber der Gedanke der CDU war
jetzt nicht rassistisch dahinter sondern
der Gewand der Gedanke war dahinter
natürlich auch haben Menschen die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft bekommen die
die jetzt unsere Polizisten an Silvester
angegriffen haben und das ist natürlich
ein Punkt den man auch ansprechen muss
gerade finde ich auch jetzt wenn es um
deutscher Staatsbürgerschaft geht wir
haben immer wieder antisemitische
Demonstrationen in ganz Deutschland
regelmäßig vor allem in Berlin vor allem
in Berlin-Neukölln wo viele Menschen in
Migrationshintergrund wohnen und
natürlich sind diese Menschen auch immer
wieder in der zweiten dritten sogar
vierten Generation wo man sieht diese
Menschen sind noch nicht integriert und
wenn wenn es jetzt Voraussetzung erfüllt
werden
Aufenthaltsstatus und Lebensunterhalt ja
das da muss man aber auch prüfen okay
ähm erfüllte auch wirklich die
Voraussetzungen mit unserem Grundgesetz
wie sind denn die Einstellungen und die
FDP die möchte jetzt die milde zu
Bedingungen machen halt dass das auch
getestet wird das ist auch ein Eid auf
die Verfassung gibt und vor allem bei
Antisemitismus halt ist jemand schon mal
auf so einer Demonstration mitgelaufen
die antisemitisch ist in welcher
Organisation ist die Person denn und ich
bin schon ziemlich schockiert was man da
so raus hat aus den Verhandlungen wie
wir auch berichten haben jetzt heute das
SPD und Grüne tatsächlich wohl das nicht
so sehen und keinen Nachbesserungsbedarf
sehen und da frage ich mich halt
wirklich wo ist da die historische
Verantwortung und es geht wirklich um
fast über zwei Millionen Menschen die
das betreffen würde die davon
profitieren und das sind schon sehr
viele und da müssen wir doch ganz genau
gucken wer da die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft bekommt und es muss
ein hohes Gut bleiben und das mit fünf
Jahren das wird nicht mehr verhandelt
werden das steht zum Koalitionsvertrag
drin da wird wahrscheinlich nichts mehr
machbar sein aber das das Sicherheit
gestellt wird wer das bekommt und was
für Einstellungen die Person hat das
muss doch ganz normal sein eigentlich
mitgehen
ich würde da nicht mitgehen weil also
nur weil dann einer Einheit wird oder da
irgendwie ein Test gemacht wird bist Du
Antisemitismus also Leute
ich mein Vorschlag ist ein Indikator ob
sich jemand hier gut einfindet geht dann
schon auch über die Zeit also wenn ich
also wenn ich acht Jahre hier mich
ordentlich verhalten habe und
Lebensunterhalt habe und die Sprache
kann und mich einbringe dann bin ich der
allerletzte der nicht sagt okay dann
sollte derjenige auch die Möglichkeit
haben deutscher Staatsbürger zu werden
warum nicht aber sozusagen die fünf
Jahre zu lassen und der FDP dann so
pseudomäßig so ein Antisemitismus Test
zu geben ist für mich ein Stück weit
auch die Leute verschaukelt
also weiterhin acht Jahre würden sie
beide sagen klar aber ich bin
realistisch das wird nicht passieren
kann
was denken sie darüber als Bürger was
würden Sie sagen acht Jahre fünf Jahre
worauf kommt es wirklich an
also wenn ich heute sehe was ich als
Selbstständiger
für Auflagen erfüllen muss Fortbildung
besuchen muss was mir alles auferlegt
wird damit ich meinen Betrieb führen
kann und darf
wundert mich eigentlich wie manche Dinge
doch sehr leicht gemacht werden und was
uns immer alles schwieriger gemacht wird
das heißt sie sagen es muss klare
Verhältnisse geben
es muss klar Regeln geben da würde ich
auch gerne noch mal Herr steiniger mit
ins Boot und bei diesen klaren Regeln
war eine Sache wo unser Staat ja auch
versagt den Flüchtlingen und Menschen
die zu uns kommen gegenüber diese lange
Wartezeit auf Arbeitserlaubnis das ist
ja wirklich ein Problem dass viele auch
hier nichts machen können und sich
dadurch auch nicht gut integrieren
können ist das nicht vielleicht eher was
wo die Ampel auch mal einsetzen könnte
zu sagen okay wie schaffen wir es denn
die Menschen die hier sind besser zu
integrieren schneller zu integrieren
ich bin grundsätzlich dagegen dass wir
Asyl und Flucht mit Arbeitsmigration
vermischen das ist der Fehler der in
diesem Land seit zehn Jahren gemacht
wird und das immer dann gesagt ja aber
wir brauchen ja denjenigen weil der bei
uns arbeitet nein diejenigen die 2015/16
oder auch jetzt kommen und sagen wir wir
brauchen Schutz wir sind individuell
verfolgt den wollen wir erstmal helfen
so und davon losgelöst brauchen wir die
brauchen wir die arbeitszuwanderung die
Fachkräfte Zuwanderung aber dadurch dass
auch die Ampel alles in einen Topf
schmeißt und dann sagt na ja und und und
die und die Staatsbürgerschaft ist dann
noch das Asset wo die Leute sagen okay
wir wollen jetzt nach Deutschland kommen
das ist ein grundsätzlicher Fehler so
das mal vorab und jetzt auf die Frage
jetzt sind da aber Leute die sind jetzt
halt in dem Land und bevor die
beispielsweise bei mir in Speyer in der
Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung über Monate dann
irgendwie rumsitzen und nichts zu tun
haben sollten wir schon auch gucken wie
können wir die eine Aufgabe zuführen wie
können die vielleicht auch ein bisschen
was dazu verdienen ähm
also da wäre ich offen nur das ist ein
ganz gefährlicher Pfad diese beiden
Bereiche zu vermischen weil sie
natürlich auch dann das Zeichen setzen
sie brauchen sich auf der Welt
eigentlich nur auf den Weg zu machen
irgendwie nach Deutschland zu kommen und
dann werden sie schon hier irgendwie
auch in Arbeit kommen aber dieses das
ist
seine Zeit ist vorbei ich würde gerne
das Schlusswort heute abend ihn
überlassen und nicht selbst ab
moderieren wenn sie noch irgendetwas
sagen möchten können Sie es gerne tun
und dann gehen wir auch direkt raus
eigentlich habe ich glaube ich alles
gesagt was zu sagen ist vielen Dank dass
Sie die Möglichkeit gegeben hat dann
beenden wir die Sendung in Gedanken an
ihre Tochter an Marie
danke ihnen vielen Dank
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall